let me start from the right to introduce
the head table on my well let me start
with the left because that is the trend
that is going from left to right had an
mow running the doctor from Cleveland a
member of the board for a very long time
who has sustained the commitment of the
Cleveland and fire community to the
objectives and purposes of the ADC
on my immediate right on your left is
aboard iya a very distinguished scholar
which I will introduce later on next to
him is Dan Mirani I'm sorry ray
irani hey Ronnie well Mezen you are
supposed to tell him that I had a
Freudian slip which is a financial
dimension of it mezzanine Ronnie is one
of the most outspoken members of the
board of the ABC he has enriched its
discourse for many years and his
commitment is unwavering and I would
like everybody to express their
appreciation for the game effort that he
has me
and then well I don't want to say
finally but Nayla Holly the chairman
chairperson of the board you know I have
to be politically correct the
chairperson of the board has steered
this organization beyond the expectation
of the optimists and therefore I would
like all of us what's the end of this
convention to give nellis le and the
members of the board the applause and
the Ovation they deserve
while my name is Clovis Maqsood allow me
and I know I will get a beating later on
to express also my great appreciation
and admiration for the work of the
president of ABC Halifax own needless to
say that the members of the National
Office of ADC have done a yeoman work
this convention would not have been
possible was it not for their commitment
dedication and clarity of purpose so
they the staff of the nav ADC stand up
where are they
I'm going to take exactly one minute to
say that last year's speech was far
better delivered by national Edward
Sayid
then what we are going to listen today
Edward side is the pride not only of the
Palestinian community but of the Arab
community and what he calls the
constituency of conscience throughout
the world may I introduce dr. Edward
thank you
okay
no no sit down please
okay thank you very much thank you very
very much ladies and gentlemen can you
hear me all right I'd like to thank the
organizers and officers of the ABC for
inviting me in spite of my non
appearance last year I think I think my
daughter's my daughte earn Angela's
performance as clovie says well far
eclipse anything I'll ever do
but you you're very patient and I'm I'm
deeply grateful for the honor you've
bestowed on us for having us here
naturally last year and me this year I'm
also grateful to Covey's who is always
such a good friend and selfless in his
support of his friends and and causes in
which he believes there very few people
like him in the Arab world or out of it
for that matter so I think everybody
recognizes his superb human qualities
I'm also pleased having been as many of
you here have been at this one of the
people who was involved with ADC at the
start to see how much a DC has done in
the last what is it 15 or 20 years of
its existence not only because it's by
far the largest Arab American
organization but also because much more
important it's has gone further than any
group before in creating a kind of
community identity for the Arab
Americans and giving them a kind of
presence in the society which we've
never had for all kinds of reasons we
come from many different parts of the
Arab world there are all sorts of things
that separate us we've come at different
times different backgrounds
different interests and associations but
I think the presence of ADC as a
protector of Arabs against stereotyping
and attacks of one sort or another and
the beginning to create a positive
identity is is truly a tremendous thing
and I think it's very important that we
that we recognize how far we've gone
we're we're we're great at recognizing
and I am too and how little we've done
but I think it's important at moments
like this to recognize that we've done a
lot and we we've accomplished a great
deal and that's something that we should
feel positive about now the topic that I
was given by halle was the arab-american
agenda or an agenda for the future
political and active which is of course
much too big a subject for me possibly
to to deal with so I'm going to talk
about it in a very partial way offering
what I can
building on personal experience because
I think in the end that's the most valid
and then I'll try to generalize here and
there but I hope also that we'll have
time for discussion and questions after
I finished now one of the things that
should be noted at the outset is that
this is a very particular time in the
history of the modern world it's not
only the end of a century and the
millennium but it's for the first time a
world that is increasingly I won't say
dominated but it's certainly
increasingly influenced by expatriate
and diaspora communities I mean if you
think that today for instance Sweden
which which is certainly the most
Swedish country in the world now has a
population of over 15% non Swedes so
this presence in many of what used to be
extremely homogenous countries like
France and Britain and elsewhere in
Western Europe but also in Australia and
other kind
trees Latin America you recognize the
presence there of large numbers of
people from other parts of the world and
of course this is nowhere more true than
it is in the United States which is of
course an immigrant society a society
made up of immigrants and in that in
that panorama of course the Arabs have a
very particular place this is a
multicultural society
and I think one of the things that a DC
has pioneered is the role of the Arab
Americans and their culture in a
multicultural society which is not only
that of the white wasps but also of
Latinos of African Americans Chinese
Asian Americans and so on and so forth
so that's a very important thing to note
that we are playing a role in this
diverse and extremely mobile world it's
a world of tremendous dynamic change for
the first time in history the national
basis of states it's changing and taking
on the identities of many new components
in them in England for example the
Caribbean and the East Asian communities
have changed Britain from a country
largely dominated by white people to
something quite different the mix is
very important I think
now the peculiar the peculiar situation
of this country I think it's even more
recognized because when I came here in
the early 50s as a student the idea was
that you studied let's say the
humanities and that was automatically
understood without any question to be
the Western humanities you read
Shakespeare you read Dante you read
Dostoyevsky you read Milton and so on
and so forth in the almost 40 years that
I've been teaching the whole idea of the
humanities has changed to a
multicultural one where the humanities
are considered to be the province of the
entire world so students today instead
of just reading although they were
important things to read Plato Aristotle
Homer Virgil etc now read the Koran they
read the great books of the Confucian
tradition they read the Japanese
tradition then even the Indian
all in keeping with the fact that the
recognition of multiculturalism in the
United States has become a fact and I
think this is a new opportunity for us
to assert our presence in this in this
new mix and I want to talk about that in
a minute what gives our situation is
Arab Americans a particular let's say
twist or tension is the fact that alone
of all the regions of the world there is
a kind of political tension between the
United States the dominant or at least
of home society in which all of us live
and the part of the world from which we
come it's not entirely coincidental that
as we speak today the United States is
still bombing Iraq I'm an average of
once every three days
that sanctions against several countries
several Arab countries Middle Eastern
countries economic sanctions against
them are maintained by the United States
that the sense most of us feel as a
community and one of the reasons for the
existence of a DC is the sense of
hostility between the United States the
dominant culture of the United States
and the Arab world which is evidenced in
the media in in in schools and and so on
and so forth I don't need to talk to you
about that you all know it from your own
experience we're still an ethnic
community racially profiled singled out
for a particularly sick Uhler form of
hostile attention so I think this gives
our situation it's it's peculiar
identity and that's what I want to talk
about especially today and both the
challenges and the realities of that and
I want to begin by mentioning to you
something which my father told me when I
first came to this country I was 15 my
father had come to America in 1911 from
Jerusalem he had escaped Jerusalem
because he was about to be draft
into the Ottoman army to fight in
Bulgaria so his father said to him you
know there's there's no point and you
were being cannon fodder for the Ottoman
army run away so he did it he came here
he lived in the United States for ten
years and during that time he served in
World War one in the American army in
Europe he served in France but the
experience of those years my father was
a very laconic man he wasn't given to
long speeches very lapidary laconic
advice and just before I left I was 15
at the time to come to boarding school
here he said to me Edward I have to tell
you something when you're in the United
States try and stay away from the Arabs
not knowing what he meant I asked him
for explanations and his one-line
explanation was the Arabs will always
pull you down that was the experience of
most I think arms of his generation that
it was a disparate community it wasn't a
community known for its internal
cohesion and indeed for the first 10 or
11 or maybe even 15 years that I was
here I had nothing to do with Arabs I
went to schools where there were no
Arabs and indeed I had very little
contact with them because I didn't live
here I was a student and it's in student
in places like the universities and
colleges I went to there were very few
Arab students so it wasn't really until
the 67 war that I found myself a member
of a community for the first time and
what brought us together as a community
was a collective defeat which gave us an
identity in this society as the peculiar
scapegoats of everything that was wrong
with the world
we were the fanatics we were the
terrorists etc etc and I've lived this
experience as have all of us in one way
or another
and I want to give you now just two or
three little anecdotes to tell you just
to give you a sense of the world I live
in which is the world of you know of the
University of thought of culture and so
on and so forth how we look in that
world in 1980 a publisher my publisher
in New York asked me to give him a list
of novels from the third world
for translation into English he was
interested in putting together a list I
mean in his publishing house which was a
commercial very well known commercial
publishing house and he said if you
could give me a list of writers from the
arab world from africa elsewhere we
might consider them for publication and
i gave him a list at the top of the list
was this was in 1980 was Negi my foods
who at the time wasn't known in this
country eight years later of course he
won the Nobel Prize and as a sign of
what that meant was that in the paper
that was written the column that was
written about his prize in the New York
Times the first quotation was from the
Israeli consul who acted they had to get
his idea do you how do you feel about an
Egyptian winning the Nobel Prize okay
back to 1980 I gave him the list and
didn't think much about it until I ran
into him a few months later and I said
to him Andrei what has happened to the
list I gave you he said well we're
proceeding with some of the two novels
you mentioned and I said what about I
gave my food you know he's a really
great novelist and although he's not
well-known I'm sure he will be well
known in time so he said well we decided
not to do it and I said why and he said
Arabic is a controversial language okay
that's that's the first story the second
story is it's about a decade later in
the early 90s there's an organization
which some of you may have heard of
called Penn's
P en it stands for poets essay its
novelists and it's a worldwide
organization of writers and there's a
very powerful pen American Center it
organized in centers in every country of
the world and pen American Center I was
I was on the board of it on the
executive committee for it and so a
number of people said to me wouldn't it
be a good idea given what you've been
saying about the ignorance of the Arabs
and of Arab culture I mean it wasn't
political it was good culture oh
wouldn't it be a very good idea I think
I may have mentioned this earlier at a
at an ABC convention but it's worth
repeating would it be a good idea if we
had a
eating of Arab and American writers
let's say we bring 15 or 20 writers from
the Arab world would get 15 or 20
prominent writers from America you know
people like Norman Mailer and william
Styron and so on and so forth and we
would have a series of exchanges
seminars meetings public readings and so
on and so forth I thought it was a great
idea and we immediately began to put
together a committee of which I was a
member and then there was a bit of a
delay and one of the delays was they
were trying to decide on I'm saying
things that are that will sound to you
shocking but they were actually said in
meetings they were looking for a Jewish
member of the committee so I said I mean
why is that an issue I mean why should
there be a Jewish member of the
committee and they said well Edward you
understand and I said well what does
that have to do with Arab writers I mean
if you are going to have an exchange
between Israeli rikers and American
writers you wouldn't think of putting an
Arab on the committee would you they
said no so I said well why in this case
so they said well it's a different
situation you understand we have a
constituency we don't want to offend
anybody
that's it all right fine we'll get so
they found somebody who seemed to be
interested in the idea but the point
about it is that we try to raise money
for it all right the budget was fairly
small I mean it was like $100,000 for a
week-long conference involving lots of
travel and writers and so it was
impossible to do anything and this
project is still on the books at Penn
and nobody wants to support it neither
neither the membership of Penn nor in
the society where one of the organizers
told me you know if this was a
conference like the one you mentioned of
Israeli and American writers we could
raise the money with one phone call but
we can't do it for because there is no
constituency for Arab culture in this
country so that's the second point I
wanted to make by way of a little
anecdote to give you an idea of where we
are and the third it's not exactly a
story but it's it's a fact that we feel
as Arabs extremely uncomfortable when
common and ordinary words have been
associated
things that make us deeply troubled take
the word piece for instance it's been
hijacked it means something quite
different than it does for us in
connection with the Middle East
take the word fanaticism and violence
and terrorism
ask anybody there was a survey done a
few years ago in Canada where the word
Palestinian was you know flash and the
the test the person taking the test was
asked to immediately say what came into
his mind in about 80% of the cases
Palestinian triggered the word terrorism
fanaticism violence etc always
associated with the Arabs with Islam
and so on and so forth I think that's
despite the efforts and very important
efforts of ADC to sensitize people to
that it's still the case that stupid
films like the seeds were made last year
and that apparently I read Ali Abu Nam
you put it out on the internet there's a
new film coming out where well sort of
like that Schwarzenegger film where he
kills 80 Arabs in two frames or
something Arabs are always being killed
they're always associated publicly in
the in the public mind and public image
with what is negative and and and
regressive I think that's the general
situation and it raises the question is
for the agenda what can be done
collectively as a community among others
here to change that not just by reacting
to a terrible film or a stereotype that
we might see in a comic or an
advertisement or a sitcom but over a
long period of time I mean what is the
agenda that we should put for ourselves
over the next 10 or 15 years given that
a that we are members of this community
here we're members of this society Arab
Americans as Americans and we have a
real continuing connection with the Arab
world which is very important to most of
us all of us travel there most of us
travel there we have historical
connections we have family connections
and of course we have cultural and
linguistic connections so the question
is what are the models
for activism what are the possible
models for activism as arab-americans
given this background which I tried to
sketch in simplifies it somewhat but in
general I think it rings true and given
also and this is perhaps the most
important point point that we are moved
by notions of citizenship we belong here
we are American citizens and therefore
we are participating in a society and
that we have to have a say in what kind
of a society this is what sort of policy
it's going to have towards the world
what kind of country this is where its
relations with the Arab world are both
very important very rich very tense and
have been problematic for a long time
it's it's a daunting challenge but I
think we have to face it and what I'm
going to propose in a very sketchy way
or a few ideas that may be of help
perhaps not but are worth it in my
opinion thinking about in discussing now
I think the first point I'd like to make
is I think it's very important to have
done what we have so far done namely to
combat stereotypes that Arabs are not
simply terrorists towelheads
camel jockeys the whole thing I mean I
grew up with them ironically my children
a generation after me also went to
American schools also grew up with them
so they're still there I think it's
important to combat them but I think the
next step is the one I don't think we've
taken and that is to give our culture
our heritage our language a real
presence beyond stereotypes in this
culture in this society in this in this
country now what that means is
what this means is I think a number of
things I mean it's important of course
that we continue with as meetings
half-lives and dub kids and associations
Ramallah Beit Hanina Lebanese Federation
all of those you might say partial or
local associations are terribly
important people give their organic but
beyond that it seems to me we have a
terrible the important responsibilities
towards making the contribution of our
culture which is really quite fantastic
if you take it take the time to look at
it make it felt in let's say the
curriculum in the Academy in the
university in the school
I can guarantee you and this is again
something for personal experience that I
travel all over the country giving talks
and so on and everywhere I go people say
can you give us the name of a book that
tells us something about the Arabs we
know nothing about them we are for
whatever reason excluded from for
instance there are every major
university in this country has a program
in Medieval Studies medieval studies
means you know Dante meets Chaucer it
means the founding of the University the
founding of the scholastic tradition etc
etc it's always assumed to mean medieval
West but the fact is I mean this is not
something that we could even debate this
is a fact that the medieval West is
incomprehensible without Arab and
Islamic civilization there's a book no
no this is great it's important there's
a book I'll give you an example this is
something that I have just learned and I
feel myself I'm sort of confessing to a
tremendous lack in my own awareness
there's a very important book by an
American Arab American professor at the
University of Pennsylvania called George
Makdissi some of you may know him I
think he's retired now but he was a
student of Louie Messina on great French
Orientalist and his book is entitled
something like how Western humanism in
the West
humanism in the West came from the
Islamic world and it's a massive tone in
which he shows that the previous notion
held by people like Jakob Burkhardt the
great Swiss historian of the Renaissance
who wrote at the end of the 19th century
was a colleague of Nietzsche's at the
University of Basel and his many of you
may have read his book the origins of
the of the Renaissance it's a study of
how the Renaissance arose in Italy in
the 15th century how people like Pico
della Mirandola Chino aeroccino Sir
Thomas More in England
all these people were influenced by
these amazing Italian humanists who
discovered the heritage really of
ancient Greece and the way he describes
it Burkhardt and the others Chris Keller
there's a whole series of important
historians it's as if it was like the
major breakthrough self generated by
these Western Italian humanists Macha
see of course who knows all of the
languages it's not only not only of
course Arabic but also Italian and Latin
and Greek and so on and so forth
in a very painstaking way shows that the
whole concept of humanism the whole idea
of the university as a place where
discussion disputation argument but what
worth what's called in the in the late
Middle Ages studia idea was in fact the
invention of the Arabs and that what we
know today as humanism was in fact
invented by Arabs in Sicily in the great
courts of Sicily of Andalusia Baghdad
etc that there is a direct link between
our culture and the cult the modern
culture of the West which is always
represented as having sprung you know
like from the head of Zeus like Athena
coming out whereas in fact there is
there is this incredible role that the
Arabs have played which is totally
unknown to students all of whom study in
American universities who study the
Renaissance as the first great step in
modernization of liberal education
humanistic interpretation and so on so
forth
there's a massive precedent for that in
the work now who's doing who is looking
into that I mean this is our role you
see this is what I'm trying to say
and beyond stereotypes beyond saying we
object to being characterized as camel
jockeys or terrorists we have to now
start to put in place precisely what it
is that we are and you can't do that by
just saying well we have a very rich
civilization or the Arabs did that you
know people used to say that Shakespeare
was an Arab really shake its bit or
something I mean that that's no good we
live we live or you know how many
Spanish words are really Arabic words
iluminage Almanac I'll say tune olives
it's and so on as they tune itself fine
that's all very nice but that's folklore
what I'm talking about is something that
every community in this country whether
it's the Asian American community the
afro-american community has done is the
discovery the articulation and the
insertion of this culture into the main
culture of the United States we have not
done this we are irresponsible in the
extreme when it comes to looking at the
curricula of universities and we cannot
do it unless we do it ourselves in other
words I think we are ourselves the
responsibility to transact the
responsibility of acquainting ourselves
at whatever level I'm not just talking
about kids I'm talking about seniors
like myself like many other people here
to understand what our heritage is and
to actively promote it it's literature
its language and so on in the society in
whatever form that it's possible whether
it's the YMCA the Rotary Club the
University the school etc ever as I say
every ethnic community in this country
every cultural community in this country
has done this except the Arabs it cannot
be done however without collective will
it can't be done by individuals of
course individuals do it in Houston for
instance I was down there a couple of
years ago or maybe it was last year
giving a lecture and I discovered that
they was starting to do it what did they
do they organized themselves and there
again overcame the differences between
Lebanese and Palestinian
and Syrians and Christians and Muslims
etc identified themselves as established
a foundation raised money and
established a professorship in Rice
University which exactly promoted the
study of the Middle East and so on I
mean I think this is a very very
important precedent to do this where the
culture at large in a sense has which
has no place for us at present largely
because we ourselves don't do it but I
was thinking also I wrote an article at
the time of the Gulf War where most
people felt I mean you know I have no as
everybody knows here I have no love at
all and I despise Saddam Hussein and
everything he represents but Iraq isn't
I mean
Iraq is not a desert country I mean Iraq
is the richest of all Arab countries in
terms of its heritage its culture and
etc it's it's it's human and natural
resources but at the time I remember
that one of the justifications for
bombing Iraq and for continuing to
bonnet today is that it's basically an
arid country there's nothing there
they're just a bunch of crazy people
running around and it doesn't matter so
I I wrote an article about what's what I
called embargoed literature how little
was known in the society about novels
about poetry about film all of this is
something that can be done at the
community level where our literature
which needs to be translated I would say
of all the major literature's in the
world today Arabic is the least
translated into English French is better
more translations into French them into
English but English we are non-existent
largely because the community hasn't
made that an imperative of its presence
in this country and that's part of
citizenship the same is true of film the
same is true of painting the same is
true of drama one here is there people
in this room here who have talked to me
about projects to bring painting and
photography and so on and so forth
this is Kent I mean fantastically
important because this is after all a
democracy it's not a police state so the
only way I mean for example our
traditional enemies in the Society of
Zionists that's how they've done it they
represent in a society a positive
valence positive value which is that you
know that Israel for example and its
cause is liberal
kradic and so on and so forth our
Israeli writers as Israeli speeches
their Israeli artists etc all the time
circulating and very little of ours is
known and I think that is I would say
the number one prerogative I think for
the future is to set Arab culture by our
own efforts in the contemporary culture
of this country the second aspect of
this cultural thing is to intervene
actively in discussions and ABC has
pioneered this I think that whenever
there's you know there's some discussion
or some reporting the example I am he's
not here so he won't be embarrassed by
my singing mouth as a young man at the
University of Chicago I'll eat a banana
me who's the most extraordinary surveyor
of the press I've ever seen in my life
he seems to do nothing but read all the
newspapers listen to all the news
broadcasts the television thing and he's
constantly on the internet bombarding
them with letters about their
inaccuracies their their you know their
their the stupidity of their biases and
so on and so forth you we have to do
that if we don't do it nobody else will
and as a result we go you know sort of
by default which is a situation I think
that can't be allowed to continue so I
think the critical intervention on the
part of individuals and associations is
terribly important to keep reminding the
world not in a narcissistic or
ethnocentric way that we are a real
people with a real culture and that we
have something very important to
contribute both historically and at
present we are very gifted writers movie
makers photographers poets etc these are
extraordinarily important the second the
first is the cultural and I tried to do
a little faster the second is the if the
political that is to say whether we like
it or not and I and I have always been
aware of this from the moment I came to
this country that you always had a
choice you could either become an
American and sort of forget your past
there was a teacher I had in boarding
school allow me to tell the story I was
very homesick I was fifteen I never left
home before I went to this boarding
school in northern
New England and I was told by a friend
in Cairo that there was a teacher at
that school who was originally from
Egypt I think he may have been a shammy
you know some kind of Lebanese or
something so I was incredibly Lebanese
or Palestine no no I
Shammi in the Arabic and the Egyptian
sense of the word anyway so I was very
so I yeah he Belarus shone so I went to
see him the second day I was there I you
know kind of timid homesick paralyzed
boy and I go stumbling around and I find
him in his house and I said to him my
name is Edward Sayid I'm from Cairo and
such and so of friend of yours who was a
classmate of yours at AEC told me to
look you up and he said oh yeah that's
all he said oh yeah so I said so I said
to him then I switched to Arabic and I
started to talk to him in Arabic and I
said you know I've just arrived from
Egypt and he told me to look you up and
that you would assist he stopped me
right in the middle of my sentence he
said in English he said I don't speak
Arabic anymore brother this is a brother
yeah I think he meant to say but he said
it in English he said brother this is
America we have to be Americans and then
I realized that there were really two
choices right you could be American
which meant in his sense of the word to
just obliterate your past and be more
loyalist
Royalists than the king you know if
we're bombing somebody we have to be
more loud about bombing it than anyone
else and the whole thing or you could be
who you really are
and be both you could be an Arab and you
could be an American somehow involving
yourself on both levels and given the
politicized nature of this society I
think really certainly all the people in
this room must have chosen the second
they're here because they admit and
identify with their Arab past and their
Arab heritage so I think there's a kind
of a double mission politically one is
to enter public life in this country
part of the debate as our Americans
you can admit it or not or not if you
like but certainly at some point your
name and your your your perhaps your
accent and and your interests will
identify you to enter public life on
issues that we have in common with many
Americans civil rights I mean I think
Arabs are naturally progressive despite
evidence to the contrary I mean some
evidence to the contrary I think we I
mean given our pasts and their sorry
situation of the Arab world today I mean
where the whole issue of human rights
and freedom of expression and you know
one thing or another I mean the Arab
world is not a model for us now so can
we be a model for the Arab world by
identifying ourselves in this country
with the progressive elements in the
women's movement and the civil rights
movement in the environmental movement
all these things that are part of
improving this country it's not America
right or wrong my father used to tell me
this all the time we had a big quarrel
about Vietnam and he said you know my
country right Iran I said Vietnam is an
imperialist murderous war he said yes
but your country right or wrong and I
said I can't agree with that the whole
idea is to challenge the rule of this
country and insert your own values which
are I think correct ones and I think
therefore we have to enter into this
into the public discussion of this
country to shape this country to turn it
into an America that we can identify
with and can live in as Arab Americans
with respect for our background language
religion and so on and so forth and of
course there until today it is the
Palestinian issue that defines the terms
of debate for Arabs in this country it
doesn't mean that every Arab here has to
be a partisan of Palestine but it does
mean that the central foreign policy
issues between the Arab world and the
United States which affects every Arab
here is Palestine and the issue of
Palestine because it is such a glaring
case of injustice is generally avoided
in public discussions people you know
Tom Hayden will go on a great length
about correctly about how terrible the
war and Kosovo is and how he's against
ethnic cleansing who isn't against it
everybody's against it but nobody
mentions Israel that Israel was based on
ethnic cleansing so I think it's it's
terribly important to enter debate in
here and associate ourselves with the
positive progressive element in this
country not the neoconservative movement
not the not the anti civil rights
movement
not the imperialist war movement I'm
thinking of people like John McCain
wants to bomb and invade it cetera et
cetera but rather those currents and
movements in this country that will help
us why will it help us and this is a
very important point and the second
point I want to make because this fight
to improve the world we live in is not
only being fought in this country by
Americans an Arab American Asian
American African American etcetera
etcetera it's also being fought in the
Arab world that is to say if you look at
every kind look beneath the cliches and
the lazy reporting of the media about
which I could talk to you great length
at some other time
but what is not reported about our part
of the world is the fact that there is a
dialectic there's a dynamic of struggle
inside the Arab world to improve the
situation for example for human rights I
mean there's an awareness in every Arab
country now that if you go to prison and
most arab countries are of course police
states in one sort or another that you
are threatened immediately with torture
it's over it's important to say of
course that Israel is the only country
in the world that legalizes torture but
at least maybe that's a positive step at
least it cannot suggest we're allowing
torture and we want to make a law pass
pass a law says that we can't torture
maybe we can improve the situation in
the Arab world where Arab countries and
AB states passed laws saying that we
want to torture - but at least we have
to take a position on it
they're now several there are now
several important Arab human rights
groups in the Arab world there there are
now quite militant struggles going on
within the Arab press which is heavily
censored not only you know in the
obvious places but in liberal countries
essentially liberal countries like Egypt
which has extremely regressive press
laws Jordan as well Jordan in this
country enjoys a reputation for a
liberal democracy and so on and so forth
but the fact is that when it comes to
the press the press Lauren Jordan is
fantastically regressive it's simply
unacceptable and alas the same thing is
true of the Palestinian press laws
freedom of accept look what it's done to
the universities universities in the
Arab world today are a disgrace because
they're essentially political
institutions you cannot advance get
promoted if you take positions that are
unpopular that are unorthodox you have
to be very safe very careful in order to
please the party please the ruler please
your colleagues who might report on you
there's no scientific research to speak
of there's no freedom of inquiry well
that's an important struggle that could
involve us many of us are academics many
of us are involved in issues of that
sort in this country and I think we
ought to also be able to identify with
similar struggles within the Arab world
the women's movement the environmental
movement does not I mean if you think of
how single-handedly the Arab world has
destroyed its natural environment
I mean think of the sea off being Syrian
Lebanese Palestinian Egyptian coast it's
dead by virtue of pesticides bombing
dynamiting fish etc etc etc to say
nothing of what's happening in the
landscape and so on and so forth
well there are groups beginning to
emerge in the Arab world and I think
it's with those that we have to identify
as part of our struggle as Arab
Americans here to do the same thing but
also there because of this double
connection that that that that that we
have so the main point I want to make
therefore is that our participation in
the political agenda in the forming of
political gender a cultural agenda for
Arab Americans is an inclusive one it
cannot be simply based upon what I have
called folklore and simply going back to
having you know haffley's and 't and
simply trying to attack and criticize
negative stereotypes I think just to
resume it quickly to put in place a
program designed to place Arab culture
at the apex at the heart of the
humanistic scientific cultural and
political traditions of the world it's
as a world culture which is contributing
tremendous amount and the only people
who can do it are people who are
relatively free to do it naming those of
us here in this country that's number
one number two intervene actively in the
political issues of this country and
third intervene politically in similar
way and whether it's a question of
Palestine with this question Human
Rights Against Torture all these things
I think in the Arab world these
struggles are going on but they're also
going on in this country which is in
many ways deeply repressive this is this
country has the largest prison
population per member of the pair of per
capita of any country in the world I
mean there are many abuses and we should
not be afraid to speak out and to take
prominent positions as many of our
community already has people like Ralph
Nader who doesn't particularly want to
identify with the Arabs but everybody
knows he's an Arab you know maybe he
doesn't know it
anyway I just want to conclude by I
since III have to say something about it
this is the last thing I wanna say which
has nothing to do with a subject at hand
which is a political agenda that's right
it is I just want to say one word or two
maybe about the Kosovo thing which is
been very much on my mind and a lot of
we've been silent on this and their
reports in the Arab world that people
are happy and that the Emirates have
sent tents and hospitals and of course
the Israelis have sent and we identify
with the Kosovars and the Albanians and
it's a kind of confused thing but I
think it's very important for Arab
Americans to remember a couple of things
number one that the United States which
is a country we pay taxes in the elect
officials mistakenly in some cases to
lead this country we have a
responsibility for the image of this
country in the world as citizens of it
and we now live in a country which is a
world the only world class bully which
bombs at will all around the world now
it's not an accident and I think you
mustn't be fooled you mustn't be fooled
by this nonsense about humanitarian
intervention I mean there have been
interventions that the United States has
blocked Rwanda in 1995 the answers have
simply refused to enter into this at all
chief United States ally Turkey is
massacring Kurds 46,000 have been killed
the United States is meeting today a
genocide will assault on the Iraqi
people the United States with Britain
you know when you say you want to
intervene in a humanitarian way you have
to make sure that the intervention isn't
going to make matters worse well in
Yugoslavia did they destroyed the
country they created I mean of course
there was ethnic cleansing by the Serbs
but it's difficult to tell and if you
ask any honest reporters not that there
are that many around but if you ask
reporters how much evidence do we
have of ethnic cleansing by Serb
paramilitaries and militaries the
evidence is very unclear very few people
have actually seen it I'm sure there was
a lot of it but there's no question also
that the million-plus refugees that have
been created largely as a result of the
illegal bombing by NATO which and to
come back to the United State two other
points to come back to the United States
this is an unconstitutional illegal war
he didn't get approval from the Congress
he was supposed to have gotten it by May
the 25th and of course if we are against
ethnic cleansing we have to go back to
the first important ethnic cleansing in
the post-world War two period namely
Palestine
so it seems to me it's very clear
Clinton and there are there are
movements in this country see the press
hasn't reported the protest against the
war in this country nor in Greece nor in
Italy nor in Germany nor in France nor
in England
there's been I mean the worst
performance of the press is I think the
last every everyone is the worst but
this is you know getting getting out of
control but the point I want to make is
that according to the terms of the
International Tribunal for Yugoslavia
that has indicted Milosevic for as a war
criminal can in my opinion and will
never have credibility unless it does
also indict Clinton as a war criminal
and there is as much
as much of what he did in Iraq in Iraq
and remember the bombing of Sudan I mean
he has now admitted that there was
absolutely no evidence for what they did
last August the bombing that factory
that the factory of course there has
been a meningitis epidemic in Sudan and
many of the medications used to come
from the Shafaat whatever-his-name-is
company which u.s. bombers destroyed as
they destroyed encampments killed
several Pakistanis in Afghanistan so
this is a lawless in my opinion the
lawless regime which is Arab Americans
as people who have a real stake in the
meaning of ethnic cleansing and the
restitution of refugees to their homes
we have to speak out as a community and
it won't do simply to say well it's
really not my field of expertise anyone
can read up on it and see what's being
done but it's in that in that spirit of
activism and intervention as exemplified
up I just would like to conclude on this
note as exemplified by our late friend
recently died whose memory I'd like to
honor for a minute here at velopment
where it doesn't matter whether you were
Pakistani or an Indian or a Bangladeshi
or a Turk or a Kurd or an Arab or French
you are a citizen of the world and we as
Arabs and as Americans we oppose
injustice we are totally opposed to the
kind of suffering that our country is
imposing on the world by its barbaric
form criminal gangster foreign policy
and I think that's part of our agenda
for the future thank you
let me I'm going to make a very unusual
extraordinary act of sacrifice
I shall abandon my comments for your
questions Hank
I'll be happy to answer questions or
there's a microphone there probably
another one
dr. Sayed I'm sandy Saban from
Bloomington Indiana we heard in the Gulf
War that the agenda was New World Order
and we know it was an oil situation what
is the real agenda of our government in
Kosovo certainly not what it's spoken to
me well all the evidence that we have
suggests that there were a number of
pressures very little to do it in the
end I think with with ethnic cleansing
and humanitarian intervention I think
you have to remember that this is a and
administration that has been saying for
as long as it's been there since Clinton
came to power in 92 that we have to
enlarge the sphere of democracy in order
for there being there to be bigger
markets for American exports I think
there's no question that to turn Europe
what's going on I think there's no
question that to turn Europe into a into
a stable zone it's very important for
the American vision of globalization and
economic domination that's number one
number two a great part has been played
all the information I've seen about this
a great part has been played in this by
bumbling internecine fighting within
Eden within the administration the
conflict between William Cohan and mrs.
Hart right whatever your name is
Madeleine Albright this you know the
idea that we have an army we have to use
it the pressure of the of the military
military-industrial complex the United
States I think it's very important for
us to understand that the United States
military budget it's 30 percent higher
than the entire military budget of of
NATO so this is this has got to go some
places Madeleine Albright once said to
Colin Powell if you what's the good of
having a big army if you don't use it so
there's that there's the testing as
there was in the Gulf War of smartbombs
you know every generation of Armant
there's that there's also the the the
fact that this is a neoliberal or I mean
people like both Blair
or rather Clinton and puppy-dog Blair
our men who never fought who were anti
Vietnam War opponents remember in the
60s and 70s and for them this is a
liberal war this is the war which is
most of the left in this country has
supported it as as intervention
humanitarian intervention whereas in
fact it is the assertion of American
power it is the notion that American
power can shape the world we have to
stand tall all of these things went into
it I believe and has have made it an
attractive on the surface and attractive
policy but it's falling apart I mean of
course nobody's thought is what's going
to happen I mean now he says the other
day Clinton says unless they get rid of
Milosevic we're not going to help them
rebuild the bill for the destruction of
Yugoslavia is concern will be estimated
a hundred and thirty six billion dollars
so we destroyed a country well I mean
there many economic opportunities there
also you have to think of it that way
there is there is the assertion of
American power the ability to fight
regional awards more than one at a time
Iraq
Yugoslavia who knows maybe someplace in
Central America next one doesn't know so
I think all of that is part of it but
the least convincing argument is
humanitarian intervention I mean that
has no role in the thing at all it's
nonsense
yes dr. Edward sight and I muchas me
enough Palestine II know I'm not sure me
in a general sense you don't know you're
too young to know these things
yeah would you comment on two areas
which we are not in as Arab Americans
and which will determine our future in
this country two areas where we're not
in one is the political arena in
Congress and in the Senate the
representatives of Arab Americans are 1%
of Arab Americans in both houses as
opposed to 43% who are of Jewish origin
so one percent to forty three percent
and yet our statistical base is about
five million to six millions so this is
one area and the second area is the area
of entertainment and media we are
totally non-existent
in media and until we learn to control
or penetrate media or films I have a
great respect for a personal friend of
mine who has done 13 films in this
country Musab Mustafa Lockett was a
person I admire a lot and all of them
are about Halloween and Friday the 13th
noting that yeah that's a very good
point
III take your point I think you're
absolutely right but yes of course yes
and then one final request and that is a
prayer why don't we start and end our
conventions with God a word to God to
bless us since we gave religion to both
Islam and Christianity why can't we do
that well I don't know I'm not the
organizer of this convention and it's
good thing I'm not because I wouldn't
invite myself here anyway to come to
come back to your two main questions
leaving the prayer aside which is not my
field that is the political and media
absence you see but they're part of what
I was talking about earlier the
generally speaking we tend to be
underrepresented in these sensitive
areas relative to our population why I
think I mean I you know there's there's
a speculation here I think most
first-generation immigrants of this
country especially from the Arab world
tend to be non-political tend to be
professionally oriented I mean they tend
to go into things like business or
medicine or engineering or that sort of
thing
and because the third reason I think
they don't have enough of the kind of
cultural background formation which I
was talking about which is absent from
our education today where we are so
anxious to become assimilated Americans
that we forget the importance of
bringing in our own background in our
own history into it so I think it's all
part of the same thing that you you
don't think of yourself as part of the
media working as an Arab you want to get
you may want to get in the media but you
don't want to do it in the way that you
mentioned iCub being the perfect example
that you see he's he's on his own he's
not part of a community effort to
represent and give prominence to a
community which is a
shanell community the same applies to
politics now there are efforts being
made Zoabi is doing it with his
political Institute or whatever it's
called where he's trying to get Arabs
involved in voter registration and so
and so forth like the early efforts of
the African American community but I
think on its own it can't work it has to
be part of a much larger based
collective organizing which really
starts with a school and where there's a
kind of consciousness of one's own
background and what one can bring to it
a and B a deeper understanding of the
way this country works generally
speaking you know I used to be amazed
he'd go to places when I first came to
this country I'd go to to Brooklyn and
visit friends like Laila have dad whom I
saw here and I've met somebody there
who'd lived in Brooklyn for 40 years
didn't know a word of English we tend to
be enclosed in our own so one has to
understand the way the system works I
think to understand the importance of
what you've mentioned the media which is
central but it media includes
broadcasting it includes writing editing
publishing filmmaking I mean it's so
many acting so it's a it's a it's a
large and complicated thing and we're
we're very early in this game but I
think we're getting there I mean I was
amazed because my daughters are now
trying to be an actress I was amazed
asking friends how many Arabs there are
in Hollywood there quite a few but
they're they're you know sort of you
know as actresses or producers and
directors there each one is by himself
there isn't a sense that they part of a
community trying to do something
together but perhaps in time that will
develop if organizations like this
develop also I've got five minutes and
I've got a run I've got a catch a plane
yeah very quick very quick we are
approaching an election year right as
you know in this country and there has
been a change in Assam in in in occupied
Palestine arrival with the new premier
considering Gore will win and I'm not
sure I'm sure you are aware of his
background yes with the Hasidic movement
and the phonetic Zionist movement and
Martin Peres and he
grandfather - and I would like you to
enlighten us about what things hide
those with the only status hope we have
is the stability of the PLA the change
is happening in America and in Israel
and the great stability of non democracy
and non freedom of speech in the occupy
West Oh still occupied was bad
yes and Gaza please elaborate thank you
well very quickly I mean first of all I
don't think it's in foregone conclusion
that Gore will win the election but I I
take your point about his being you know
probably worse than Clinton I I think
we're fooling ourselves to believe that
the situation is now one that we can
really influence I think the situation
in Israel given the new election of
Barack there's been a lot of euphoria
expressed about you know what a
wonderful change and so on in many ways
I think he's probably worse than
Netanyahu because he's like Netanyahu
he's an Arab killer I mean that's his
key whole career you saw what he did
with a ten with a ten Arab now ten or
twelve
Arab parties in the Knesset he simply
ignored them in talking about you know
the future I think he's a hardliner I
mean his whole political discourse was
such I think also the kind of lamentable
I didn't whether it's stupidity or
slavish Ness falling civility of the of
the Palestinian Authority in welcoming
Barak and how this is a great moment for
peace and all this time it's complete
[ __ ] now I don't think I don't think
I I don't think I don't think much can
be I don't to be I mean really to give
you the short answer a question I don't
think we can do much as a community in
the next election whether as a result of
the Israeli election or the American
election what we can do is a try to
educate our people to a better and
that's something I missed out entirely
I'm talking about but as a community
lives here it's our duty to explain to
people in the Arab world what this
country really is about you know I mean
when leaders come here and all they want
to do is to sit in the White House and
be photographed next to Clinton and
talking I mean that's not what it's
about
we've never tried we've never tried to
do what we need to do with this is to
organize a massive Human Rights Campaign
in this country for example for
Palestinian rights never did that
I think that's number one number two we
have to make sure that it that
institutions in Palestine and in the
Arab world non governmental institutions
which are threatened by the Palestinian
Authority which are threatened by the
Egyptian government which has passed a
very repressive war against NGOs that
these civil institutions are
strengthened despite the efforts of the
government's various governments to
stifle them and above all to try to
promote discussion and open exchange
within the Arab context to talk about
the future in some meaningful way as
opposed to just running after the United
States the United States is not the
solution of our problem it is our
problem as Arabs and as Americans and
more and more of the world more and more
of the world is recognizing it it's
quite stunning as a result of this cause
of a thing
how many commentators on the right right
wing commentators like Sapphire
Rosenthal etc are beginning to realize
that the United States has really played
itself a very bad role by turning itself
into the world's biggest bully and
anti-americanism is on the rise
everybody's aware that this is a country
that can't need but we haven't devised
specially in the Arab world we haven't
devised a system a method for dealing
with the United States and I think
that's important for people like us I
think
then let me in a very nonpartisan way
say Oh Lord
thank you for the grace that has made
the ABC convention this year the most
successful convention let us also hope
that Edward sight will be able to
continue his struggle not only for the
human rights of all not only for the
cultural integrity not only for his
dynamic intervention into civilized
discourse but also hope that he would
have full health to undertake the
intellectual revolution which would
deliver for us Palestine and Jerusalem
as its capital
Mezen than now Ellen Helen members of
the board and members of a DC
congratulations good day